awesome all right so this is uh millions
of users purely functional code i'm
richard feldman
um so uh as claude previously mentioned
i work for a company called no red ink
and basically we help teachers teach
writing through software
um i joined back in 2013 uh this was the
team there's also one person who was
remote but at the time we were all in an
office although now we're fully remote
uh and this is true before kobit we're a
very remote company um we have people in
the us and canada and
uh argentina uh
brazil
various places in europe um we're quite
a distributed team nowadays but back
then very small company um but it's been
you know quite some time since 2013 and
a lot has changed um so
comparing some things that have changed
between 2013 and now uh we had five
employees then probably by the end of
the year we will be over 100 employees
um of that about a quarter will be
engineering and the rest is like sales
and you know uh curriculum and stuff
like that um at the time i actually
did a checkout on the day that i started
it was almost 60 000 lines of code in
the whole code base um and now it's a
little over like 1.2 million
all told
back then we had thousands of users now
we have millions of users
um and back then uh when i joined we had
no money uh we
except for what investors had given us
um because uh when i interviewed that
was actually one of the questions that i
sort of grilled the ceo on i was like
now is this not this is gonna be one of
these silicon valley companies that just
never sells anything and just takes
keeps taking investor money until it all
runs out and he was like no no we
haven't planned and sure enough uh he
was right and actually last year was the
first year that we turned a profit um as
in like between the end of the beginning
of the year in the end we had more money
in the bank account than uh at the
beginning and that was not because we
took out any investment or anything
which we didn't but just from money from
customers um i should note that that
probably will not be true again in 2021
2020 was a weird year for lots of
companies no reading concluded um and
that was somewhat of an unusual
circumstance but it did at least
demonstrate like hey this can be a
profitable business certainly um and
we're you know uh right at that line
even though our preference would be to
sort of like grow rather than
aiming for profitability or maximizing
profitability
um
and of course when i joined the company
we didn't do any functional programming
at all um it was just a stock sort of
ruby on rails uh we used coffeescript
which back in 2013 was a a lot more
common choice than it is today um and
today uh we're sort of all in on
functional programming like pure
functional programming helm on the front
end haskell on the back end uh mixed for
some of our operational stuff uh we're
really like sort of all about pure
functional programming
um
so i want to talk about how we got there
um and how like what functional
programming has done for our business uh
because i know that a lot of talks are
about sort of like the theoretical nice
things about fp about like you know it's
conceptually nice it's elegant um but
this is about a business this is about
like you know we built up a company um
on the back of fp and how we did it
um so let's start with rails because
this is where we were when i joined the
company um if you're not familiar with
ruby on rails uh it's basically
ruby is a dynamically typed programming
language rails is a framework that deals
from with everything from uh
did how you deal with the database
through an orm uh to like how you render
your front end it's very opinionated
sort of famously so um and it's got a
lot of uh sort of uh
sort of web specific stuff going on
there um rails sort of like wants to own
your whole stack and uh and generally
that's how people use it sort of like a
one big monolithic rails application
um uh
also in 2013 um out slightly shortly
after i joined the company um
uh i found out about this talk uh that
was sort of making the rounds um this is
called js apps at facebook but really uh
you might think of this now as the react
talk because this is where they
introduced react to the world and open
sourced it that previously had just been
used internally at facebook um react
today is probably the most popular
actually i said probably it's definitely
the most popular way to do front-end
applications um but at the time this was
kind of a new thing we were actually
early adopters of react um
so back then uh back in 2013 it was like
the appeal of it uh to someone like me
was this functional style of rendering i
had a co-worker in a previous job who'd
really encouraged me to try out
functional programming and i'd sort of
done some like functional style stuff in
previous jobs but um react really seemed
like it was like going more in that
intentionally in that direction than any
of the javascript libraries i'd used
before
um seemed like a pretty nice api to me
uh seemed like a good way to admit like
deal with state it had kind of a good
story around that relative to other
tools that i've been using like angular
js and stuff like that
um it also seemed pretty well supported
it didn't seem like some like flash in
the pan you know kind of like someone's
weekend project this was like they've
been using it at facebook for quite a
while and they were you know open
sourcing what they were already using in
production so
it seemed like it was a
relatively safe thing to try out and
seemed like they could bring some
benefits
so what we did was a controlled
experiment we basically
said okay let's let's try to figure out
how we can find a low-risk project
that's like a good fit for this
technology we're trying to evaluate this
is kind of our recipe for how we have
tried new things out at no red reading
um step two like get it all the way into
production like just get this small low
risk project into production so don't
try to pick something like big this is
going to take a long time um just
something small and you know get it all
the way to production in such a way that
you know if it turns out that the
project doesn't pan out well it's okay
we picked a low risk one anyway and uh
we can always you know roll it back if
we end up being unhappy with it um of
course if we are happy with it then we
can just sort of expand incrementally
from there such that each individual
step we take is low risk and then
eventually if it looks like okay we've
got a sizeable thing going here like
react actually seems like what we want
to do for our whole front end let's
adopt it and that's exactly what we did
so we ended up basically deciding um
let's go ahead and
adopt react
now i want to
take a moment to talk about typescript
because typescript existed when uh
actually before react was open source
this was a talk from uh go to 2012 um uh
like introducing typescript to the world
um
but maybe it's hard to remember now
because typescript is now in fact
typescript and react is uh is probably
the most popular way to do new frontend
projects these days in the web world um
but back then typescript was not taken
very seriously um i mean to be fair
react had a lot of detractors when it
first came out but but i mean you gotta
remember that at the time typescript was
coming from microsoft and in the web
world microsoft was far and away known
for one thing which was not vs code yet
it was
internet explorer
not exactly a good brand to have if
you're a web developer like you're the
uh microsoft is the source of all of our
paint i remember when i joined no
reading we were supporting internet
explorer eight
and uh that was not a fun experience
so for microsoft to come out and say hey
web developers uh we've made this
amazing tool for you it's like uh-huh
really yeah
you don't say
um
but obviously you know over time
typescript got more and more adoption
and uh now it's quite popular now i
bring up typescript because in 2013 the
idea of using react with typescript uh
was completely outlandish this was not
something that was it was it was as far
from mainstream as you could get um
but i bring this up because we actually
had a problem which ended up leading us
to l now before i get to the l part i
just want to take a second to talk about
like basically why didn't we end up
using typescript to solve this
particular problem the problem that we
had was essentially that we were using
uh react and plain javascript okay it
was actually coffeescript but same basic
idea so no type checking was sort of the
root of the problem that we ended up
having
the problem that we had was we were
building this feature and we really care
about efficacy at no rate we really want
our features to not just work in the
traditional sense but like to actually
have an impact on the students and
as it happened this feature was for
teaching active voice and passive voice
which is a pretty tricky thing to teach
especially the middle schoolers and what
we found was that the design we came up
with once we would take it out to a
classroom and try it out we'd find that
the students just weren't getting it it
wasn't effective so we'd go back to the
drawing board and revise it and go bring
out another version sort of like an mvp
that we could we could try out on the
next group of students and that one
would also fail we'd go back to the
drawing board and we kept iterating on
this but what i noticed was that in
between these iterations it was taking a
really long time to get something
working again
that was able to actually you know uh be
usable in a classroom i mean it couldn't
just be smoke and mirrors they had to
actually be able to use it well enough
to see whether or not it was going to be
effective with them
and in part that was because
you know back in the javascript era um
pretty much the only tool we had to help
us like make substantial changes you
know like almost on the level of a
rewrite but not quite um were tests and
as it happened these changes were so big
that we basically have to throw out all
the tests um every time we made a these
substantial changes so types would have
helped out a lot but you know the idea
of using typescript is like yeah that
that's not that's not really on anyone's
radar um but elm was on our radar by
coincidence because i had personally as
for some side projects been using elm
outside of work and i really liked it um
i thought that it was an amazing
language it was really ergonomic um you
know the friend who had been
recommending functional programming to
me uh had basically talked about haskell
and elm felt to me like i could get a
sort of haskell-like experience not
having actually used haskell
in the browser which was where i wanted
to to work i was sort of a front-end ui
specialist at the time
and so i'd been using elm and i was
thinking wow when i use elm and i need
to make big changes like this i don't
have to have any tests helping me out i
have the compiler helping me out and
that's largely because of type checking
rather than functional programming and i
want to acknowledge this to make the
point that to be perfectly honest if we
had been exactly the same position
except today instead of back then
we probably would not have adopted l we
probably would have gone with what
everybody else did namely typescript
because
that was just the obvious low risk thing
to do um if you're having trouble with
with types you probably go typescript in
this day and age um and we really would
have missed out on a lot so i feel
pretty fortunate that typescript was not
as popular as it is today because i know
a lot of people who are using elm on the
front end and typescript on the back end
or who use typescript at work for their
front end and uh elm in their personal
time let me tell you it is not the same
thing it's not just the types
it's a it's a very big gap and in fact
we still get a lot a lot of applicants
who are coming from typescript jobs
because they want to use l more on that
later
okay but if you're not familiar with l
um let me just give you a quick
breakdown on what it is so elm is a pure
functional programming language it
compiles to javascript but other than
compiling to it it really has no
relation to javascript elm has its own
language designed from scratch it has no
javascript semantics except by
coincidence
it's really just its own completely
separate language and it basically
treats javascript as like
byte code that it's compiling too
that's the only it's only relationship
it does have javascript interop if you
want but that would be true regardless
of what it was compiling to
um so what do i mean by pure functional
what i mean is that all elm functions
are pure so no side effects everything's
immutable elm has full type inference
like 100 never gets it wrong um and it's
also completely sound type inference so
it uh unlike typescript which famously
has an intentionally unsound type system
the album type system actually is sound
um there's no null or undefined either
elm has the best package manager and
when i say the best package manager i
want to clarify because you might think
that i'm saying elm has the best package
manager of any programming language i've
ever used which it does by far
um i i also spent a lot of time with
rust and i went to a meetup where
someone was giving a presentation on
russ and they were like rust has the
best best package manager i've ever used
and i thought ah this is a person who
hasn't used elm neat um rust for the
record has the second best package
manager i've ever used um but yeah if
you haven't used elms um just a quick
taste it enforces semantic versioning
what i mean by that is if i try to
publish a package which makes a breaking
api change like i change a type or i
delete a function or something like that
that would be a breaking change that
would break compilation it actually will
not let me publish the package unless i
bump the major version number so the
experience of upgrading packages in elm
is unlike what i've experienced in any
other language because it just works
like i go to upgrade things and then
it's just a very nice pleasant
experience and even if there is a
breaking change which does happen from
time to time the compiler helps me
through it because
helm has the nicest error messages of
any programming language i ever used um
again i'll draw a comparison to russ
because it's another language i'm
familiar with um i've also seen people
say wow russ has the best error messages
i've ever seen um uh if you've had that
feeling i would encourage you to go read
the blog post where they announced uh
their their sort of
effort to revamp rust's error message
and improve them because you'll see in
that blog post they talk about what
we're aiming for is to make our error
messages like elm and i would say they
did a pretty good job of it rust's error
messages are quite nice um
but this is still the gold standard in
my book i still have not seen uh rust or
any other language like come close to
that so if you've not given elm a try uh
please give it a shot uh because this is
a great experience when you pull these
things together
um a quick taste of that so this is an
example of these error messages um i
just pulled this out of some random file
in our code base uh this is like our
file that like reports errors to bug
snag which is what we use for error
tracking um so this is a tight mismatch
so this book snag config record does not
have a release stage field and it's
highlighting this thing that's uh
underlines like okay why doesn't have a
release stage field and the answer is
because i made a typo it says this is
usually a typo here are the bug snag and
fig fields that are most similar
and you might notice that i have
misspelled a release stage as release
stag which is not quite right and then
it says it just suggests hey so maybe
release stage should be released
or vice versa um which is exactly the
typo that i made um this is a pretty
representative error message uh like
it's similar with like other like types
of tightness matches or other types of
errors the compiler just really gives
you as much contextual help as you can
and i have not seen another language
that does it as well as elf does
so
having had a good experience with elm
with my side projects and uh knowing
that we had this problem with react and
typescript not really being a
reasonable option to consider back in uh
at the time it wasn't 2013 i think this
was uh 2015 actually maybe 2014. um we
decided to do another controlled
experiment to see about adopting ellen
so again find a low risk project that's
a good fit get it all the way into
production and then either expand it
directly or back out
so that's what we did um we introduced
it on just like one part of one page um
as it happened it was uh this this same
uh oh sorry this is not this is not the
active voice packet voice this is a a
different thing where we had um
lots of it's basically a drag and drop
interface where there was a lot of
complicated rules around this because
you could actually pick up uh sort of
like chunks of a sentence at once and
the wrapping rules got pretty
complicated because we wanted these to
look like um real sentences so if you
drop this you know in between berries
and new for example
we would want to wrap in the middle of
this chunk so that it wouldn't you know
uh like jump all the way to the next
line and have a really awkward break
right there but at the same time we also
wanted that when you picked it up it
would sort of snap back into being sort
of one contiguous block like this so
there were a lot of tricky things to get
right about this uh from the perspective
of business logic but hey like great
complicated business logic almost
awesome at that um you know i mean it's
awesome rendering as well but uh we knew
that this would help us out here and of
course if we didn't like it well it was
all you know behind the scenes it wasn't
even doing any rendering um so it'd be
pretty easy to just back it out throw it
out and just rewrite just that one small
chunk of stuff and you know uh
javascript or coffeescript or whatever
so we did and we liked it and we started
using it more and more so such that you
know in 2013 we adopt a little bit of
react 2014 we sort of solidified our use
of react and then 2015 uh was when we
introduced that that first experiment of
elm and then 2016 it pretty quickly grew
and grew and grew just as react had
before until it basically took over our
code base and today essentially
everything except for really really old
legacy code that we haven't bothered to
touch in years um literally years uh is
all an elm yeah except for a tiny bit of
javascript interop for some like there's
like a wysiwyg rich text editing thing
that we use in javascript for example
there's a couple of really small things
that we do js interrupt with but 99
point something percent of our code base
is held uh for for our front end um so
it really took off from those sort of
small humble origins of a small
controlled experiment
um
okay so uh this is a talk about our
business so let me just sort of
enumerate the top three benefits to our
business that i've seen um you know
retrospecting over the past i guess six
years now of having used element
production um i'm gonna go in reverse
order because the first one might
surprise you
so number three uh more reliable
software so we've had basically zero
production crashes um there was a blip
in 2018 where we we finally got our
first runtime exception and the
aforementioned bug snag blogs um
that actually originated from elm code
as opposed to from javascript code that
we were doing interop with
um
basically what happened was we we used a
language feature that was potentially
capable of crashing that feature is
actually no longer in the language so if
we've been using the version of elm that
we're using today even that one wouldn't
have happened we'd still have a spotless
record but alas we did use it we did
have a crash and uh ironically i used to
tell people we'd had no um runtime
exceptions and i think a lot of people
wouldn't believe me and then once i said
uh we finally had one everyone believed
me like oh your error reporting is
working uh
it just it just actually almost crashing
um and almost designed to be that way i
mean it's uh it's not impossible to
crash an lmap i mean we did it but also
like you can still get stack overflows
there's still like a couple of ways
there's like i think there's seven of
them that you can seven different ways
you could possibly crash an lmap but the
point is that it's so hard to do
accidentally that in practice it's very
rare like when i go to speaker dinners
back in the before times when we had
in-person conferences and stuff at ellen
conferences i i it was like a fun game i
would do i'd uh ask the speakers like
hey how many of you using element
production at work you know several
hands go up i'd ask them how many of you
ever gotten a runtime exception that
were in production and all the hands
would go down i think one time somebody
told me that they had a runtime
exception it was some very unusual case
um but this is only the the third most
beneficial thing that i think we've
gotten out of hell if i'm being honest
second one is actually just
making changes be faster and cheaper um
so when i say making changes what i mean
is like changes to the software so you
know this is a company that's been
around for about eight years like you
know it was there were some people
working on it before i joined of course
um and uh
the amount of time that it takes us to
modify like existing code that we've had
and like get it to a point where we're
confident shipping it again is just
great it's really really fast um
i don't think elm is quite as fast like
even even now like being being an expert
in elm um i would be able to ship
something new in l faster than react
because it's been so long since i've
done react but i remember like what it
was like back then and if i'm being
honest i do think it was a little bit
faster to ship something if i'm if i'm
just like like a prototype or something
like that my rule of thumb was sort of
like if it's gonna take a month or
longer i think elm will be
will more than pay for itself and end up
being faster within that time period but
any project that's like less than a
month in duration uh maybe will not pay
for itself um in terms of like
turnaround time but
over time i mean we end up spending much
more time going back and making
modifications to existing things
building on top of what we built before
all of that stuff is definitely much
faster than it was before i can't
personally compare element to typescript
because we sort of like jumped over that
went straight from you know untyped
javascript to elm um but from what i
hear other people like comparing their
experiences with typescript and their
experience with elm this is still true
just not to the same degree as it would
be comparing elven javascript um but
again this is our story about our
business and the number one benefit to
our business and like i said i think
this will come as a surprise to people
and i think this is uncontroversial if
you ask the leadership at the
engineering department at norway is
hiring
it is so much easier to hire people
because we use l
and i mentioned this might be a surprise
because there's this meme and i
understand where it comes from i assumed
the same thing before we actually
started using elm um which is that oh if
you use like a you know sort of a niche
functional programming language like
elmer haskell you won't be able to hire
anyone it's the opposite it's so the
opposite i can't even express to you how
far the opposite it is
i don't know how we ever hired anyone
before we had helped um we used to
struggle to find front end engineers
like after me like i was hired with the
title of like front end engineer it was
two years before we found someone who we
liked and who was willing to join our
company
because we didn't have anything to make
us stand out it's like hey we're using
react it's like yeah
you and everybody else you know
tell me what's actually special about
you but when we say we're using elm
there's a lot of people out there who
would love to use element work but they
can't because most companies are afraid
of it ironically because they're afraid
they won't be able to hire anyone
um so it's it's such an amazing benefit
that like i can even just talk openly
about it and i know that most companies
are not going to bother or maybe they
won't believe me i don't know but um it
continues to be our secret sauce uh it's
even though it's not really a secret um
we shot it from the rooftops and then i
mentioned like i will right now we're
hiring
um and that's that's kind of how it
works um and i've heard the same thing
from other companies like i know we're
within the whole community we're
particularly prominent like elm
organization um evan schiflicki who
created elm worked here for like three
years um and you know we have a lot of
like prominent members of the home
community and conference organizers and
stuff working here um but even for
companies that's not the case like uh
what i've heard from them is that
they've had an easier time finding good
programmers um
i don't know what it's like if you're
you know kind of like just trying to
hire in bulk like just just going for
sheer numbers rather than
trying to find really strong programmers
um but from most companies that i i seem
to find interested in elm are kind of
looking for more of like strong
programmers uh
anyway so
um i'm not kidding when i say that's
like the number one benefit and to give
an example is literally earlier today we
just hired a new recruiter and she was
talking to me and just you know kind of
like getting to know you stuff um and
she was like yeah like i've been sitting
on a couple of interviews with people
and it seems like everybody wants to
work here because of this elm thing like
what's uh what's that all about you know
like she doesn't even need to know what
it is like you can't you can't not know
that if you're a recruiter for a company
that uses l like it's just it's going to
come up because that's that's just a
draw
um
so that to me is if i'm being honest i
mean i know it's a non-technical benefit
but like the benefit of the business is
really difficult to overstate how great
it's been
um
okay
yeah that's a something like a magnet
for strong programmers um
okay but uh not everything has benefits
everything has cost too so let's talk
about the top three costs of the
business um number three this comes as
no surprise the package ecosystem for
elm is smaller than npm
a lot smaller i mean npm is like the
biggest package ecosystem in existence
mostly that doesn't matter in the sense
that um like npm has i think it's last
count it was like a gazillion packages
um
99.99
nine percent of those packages you never
use i never want to use there's you know
there's it's just like there's a finite
set of packages that you actually want
um you know in the world as a someone
making software um and there's just
these like small set of them that are
important to you but it definitely does
come up that you know sometimes there's
something where we're like i really want
a
calendar picker that has these
particular characteristics and the
calendar pickers and the ellen package
ecosystem like none of them happen to
have that particular combination of
things that we need for our particular
calendar paper literally that example
came up once um and we ended up using
javascript interop which was you know it
didn't feel great but uh what can you do
um number two and this is kind of a
variation of the third one but it is
different in kind of an important way
which is fewer off-the-shelf sas
integrations so i showed you some bug
snag code earlier when we first adopted
bug snag as our production error
tracking system um you know they have
off the shelf they're just like hey
here's if you want to integrate with bug
snag here's javascript bugsnag.js just
go ahead and use that but if you want to
use elm that doesn't really exist and
unless you've gotten lucky and found
that you know some other company happens
to be using exactly bug snag um in elm
community um you know you basically need
to write your own integration or use the
job search one through interop and so we
ended up writing our own like you know
bug snag elm package and you know open
sourcing it um but i found that this one
comes up a lot more often than the
number three version like in general if
we're looking for a package like
something that's a really common use
case usually we can find it like more
often than not but when it comes to some
particular third-party company tool that
we're using it's like the opposite um
more often than not we're just like
prepared that like if we're integrating
with a new system we're probably going
to have to write our own integration
against their like raw http now i know
that some people consider this to be
like the end of the world like this the
actual apocalypse when you have to do
this
we it's such a drop in the bucket like
we just don't care i mean like like yes
we had to write our own bug stack dot
elm it maybe took us like a week like
it was fine like elm has so
astronomically more than paid for itself
like compared to the number of times
we've had to do that which has been like
two or three um it's just not even close
so like we don't consider that a
significant drawback but i mentioned it
because a lot of people do and if i'm
honest even though it's not very
significant drawback i mean obviously we
consider the benefits to for all
weighted costs um you know it is the
number two the number one actually was
just a 2018 version upgrade took a long
time for us uh this was elm 0.18 to 0.19
and the specific reason it took us a
long time was well i mean there was a
couple reasons but basically there were
a number of breaking changes that
happened to uh be pretty pervasive
across our code base we liked all the
upgrades um like it was definitely like
once we finished the upgrade we were
very very happy with uh with all the
improvements but it did take a long time
um
since then though the language has been
quite stable um there's there's been one
release since then and it was a like
minor release that you would just
upgrade to you didn't have to like do
anything um and it looks like the next
one after that is also going to be most
likely a minor release with like no
breaking changes um
but you know uh if you're if you're on a
like pre 1.0 language you know part of
the reason for having l b uh not say is
1.0 even though it's you know been quite
a few years now um is to communicate
that like yeah breaking changes are
going to happen and fair enough this was
a significant cost that we had to pay to
make that upgrade and although we
considered it worth it it was the number
one cost that i think our businesses
paid um to use zell but i mean i guess
if you're coming in today you won't have
to go through that because you're
probably building on the the current
release anyway
okay
so um so that was element like 2015 um
so in 2016 it comes around and we're
sort of reevaluating rails
we've been using it for our back end
since the beginning
and we're getting kind of unhappy with
it because of something that i will talk
about later called the database
apocalypse among other things um but
like i said more on that later
um but basically we come to the
realization that um we like functional
programming and we want to do it on the
back end too and rails is not hospitable
to that um there are some languages
where you can sort of do a functional
style like i've heard of people doing
functional style python functional style
javascript is actually quite popular um
functional style ruby is not a thing um
and so we started looking around and
asking ourselves like okay what could we
move to instead
um
basically anything was fair game uh we
didn't have any you know preconceived
notions around like well it's got to be
like this or that or the other thing or
like oh let's rule this out and rule
that out we were just like yeah open any
ideas any language you can think of
we'll consider it as a potential target
for our back end so on here we got
from left to right that's f sharp elixir
java scala closure o camel idris type
script because by 2016 typescript was
like becoming more of a thing
rust and of course haskell which is what
we ultimately sell on
but um
we didn't actually start with uh with
haskell so remember i talked about elm
is a pure functional language that
compounds javascript all functions are
for full type reference best package
manager necessary messages um
well although uh
elixir is not
these things
um it was what we actually ended up
trying first um so elixir is a
functional language that doesn't compile
the javascript rather it compiles to
erlang's bmvm bytecode
and it has a great concurrency and fault
tolerance story
doesn't actually have a type system but
it does have a static analyzer which we
had hoped would give us some of the same
benefits as a type system um spoiler
alert didn't didn't really work out that
way um
it has a nice package manager like not
as nice as elms but it's it's totally
reasonable um and if especially if
you're coming from ruby it has a nice
learning curve because elixirs like
syntax and sort of style is very ruby
inspired so our hope was that this would
be kind of a nice natural transition
from ruby to elixir especially because a
lot of the ruby community was going from
ruby to elixir um at the time and uh and
and that we would end up seeing some of
the same sort of benefits that we we'd
gotten from elm
unfortunately it just didn't work out um
elixir is a fine language it's not like
it was you know bad we actually you know
uh we did our our usual control
experiment and we actually still have
two services from that control
experiment running in production today
they're still running they're fine um
but uh but you know it just didn't end
up meeting what we were we'd ended up
getting out of it what we had gotten out
of elm and it didn't feel like it was
worth it to transition to something that
was an improvement but not as much of an
improvement as we were hoping to see
which led us to haskell so haskell is a
pure functional language which compiles
the binary executables so elixir did
allow side effects
haskell does not much like elm uh so all
functions are pure um again full-time
inference sound types a sound type
inference a bigger community than elm um
i i cannot say that it has uh the nicest
package manager around because um
russ is number two my my the nicest
package manager i've ever used uh
haskell is not number three um
but it does have also a bigger ecosystem
than l um uh and i have this in the in
the slot where with elm i had the nicest
error messages and let's just say that
haskell is not in contention for nicest
error messages um at least among
languages i've used and i've used a lot
of languages
um so uh we did a controlled experiment
with haskell as well so find a low-risk
project that's a good fit get it all the
way into production and then expand
incrementally or back out
um so we did and um this is an example
of one of the cool things that sort of
came out of that experiment this is a
screenshot from
part of our code in the postgresql typed
library and basically what you're seeing
here is a function called to app.modify
exactly1 passing in
don't worry about what log and dv do
but basically what we have here is an
inline sql query and what's cool about
this is that it's actually validated not
just syntactically
but against our database schema and our
haskell types so when i say insert into
this tutorials table and i want to
insert the name and description
this string interpolation syntax right
here is going to actually do not only
syntax checking but type checking
against the local name variable and the
local description variable to make sure
that these match the types of those
columns
and because we have not only this which
gives us compile time errors if we're
trying to do stuff with our database
that's you know mistyped or mismatched
and we also have this integration called
servant elm which basically
lets us define types in haskell and then
automatically generate serialization
deserialization code
in elm so it can go across the wire from
server to client without having to you
know do that manually
we've actually had it happen that we
changed a column in our database and had
one of our front end tests fail because
we have that completely integrated
all the way across really nice um
especially compared to what we were
doing before
um so uh we started off on rails um and
i mentioned earlier that we had this
thing uh called the database apocalypse
and uh basically the i'm going to give
you the short version of this story
there's a blog post that i'll link to in
a second that tells the full story but
essentially what happened was that we'd
run into something of a scaling problem
which is to say that you know millions
of users great awesome right well
millions of users on a site that's all
about students answering questions and
stuff had translated into billions of
questions which again great um we did
have an uh an embarrassing incident
where we uh we ran out of primary keys
because uh 32-bit integer only goes up
to 2 billion oops
that was a fun one to fix
but basically uh
we we started doing some math and
figuring out you know if we keep growing
at this rate um we're actually in
jeopardy of running out of space on the
biggest individual single server that
amazon will rent us
um
that wouldn't be good because that's
basically like well we just can't have a
database anymore we can't put new stuff
in the database
which
then hence the name the database
apocalypse
now this doesn't sound that bad you
might be like well why don't you just
shard why not just you know add some
more databases and just like you know
balance between them well the problem
that we were finding was that our rails
code was so brittle that whenever we
tried to make incremental progress on
this like we would we would say like
let's just do a little like two-month
you know little two-month project to try
and like incrementally move us towards
something that's actually you know
closer to horizontally scalable we did
this more than once and every single
time it just broke so many things within
rails that we ended up having to
completely roll it back
um so of course every time we did this
we're like this is more and more
concerning how do we solve this problem
and i don't want to completely spoil all
the details of the blog post but the
short answer was what we found was
take the rails code
rewrite a chunk of it in haskell so it
doesn't do anything different it's just
in haskell now and because we didn't
change how anything works in the entire
rail system there's no like threads to
pull on and you know things to uh to to
get out of whack with or out of sync
with one another um it was doing exactly
the same thing as before just doing it
over here in haskell instead of in rails
we're able to incrementally sort of
brick by brick moved all the pieces over
until we had enough of it in haskell
that now we could just make changes on
the haskell side and by doing that long
story short we were able to avert the
apocalypse and get a new system set up
and the result of this is that now
actually today
most of our traffic goes through haskell
like this is our highest traffic like
part of our system um by lines of code
we still have more ruby code than
haskell because it's just had a many
year head start on haskell um but we are
you know partly as a consequence of this
but also you know because of for several
other reasons basically
haskell is now you know
on the back end is for us what elm is on
the front end like that's what we want
to do all of our new projects in that's
what we want to move existing projects
over to you know whenever possible um
it's just uh it's it's it's sort of like
night and day what we were able to
accomplish in terms of this
basically the number one scariest
technical problem like biggest threat to
the business that we had
haskell was the way that we solved that
problem um
as you know business cases go it doesn't
really get much better than that um for
for demonstrating the value of a
technology to a company
um if you want to hear the full story of
that uh here's a link uh i'll show you
the slides afterwards you don't have to
like you know screenshot that or
anything but you know that'll that'll
also work
okay so um top three benefits to our
business for haskell um pretty different
than for elm um
number one here was just making changes
faster and easier i mean literally we
were unable to successfully make the
change we needed to make with rails but
with haskell we actually were able to do
it and you know avert the apocalypse
um
number two hiring again like uh we
are let's see i think our three most
recent hires
um
well one of them okay one of them hasn't
actually signed the offer yet so i
shouldn't count my chickens but uh
have actually were people who came to
the company um uh interested in
at least haskell and in some cases
hassle and didn't even know about elm um
so again like this is something that
attracts people to companies if you're
if you're looking to hire strong
programmers um i think using haskell is
a good way to do that and if anyone
tells you you won't be able to hire
anyone ask companies who actually use
haskell if that's been their experience
because i bet their experience is going
to be more like ours than like what you
might assume not given that information
and then of course uh faster more
reliable software um
when i say faster so we did have a
pretty a relatively direct comparison of
like what our haskell code was doing in
production um compared to our ruby code
now in fairness ruby is not known to be
a particularly fast language haskell
actually is known to compile to
relatively fast code um especially if
you're using strictness everywhere which
we are um
and uh so although it's not quite apples
to apples in the sense that the haskell
code is doing slightly less because part
of the whole reason we needed to change
things was to offload somewhere
elsewhere but
it's pretty comparable in terms of like
what the haskell code was doing compared
to the old ruby code that it replaced
and it's about 10x faster like as in the
throughput is about 10 10 times higher
meaning that our theoretically uh you
know our our costs for dealing with that
traffic um or at least that that that
part of the logic are uh like one-tenth
what they were before in terms of a
number of servers needed etc
so that's also benefit to the business
although if i'm honest like that's not
the main benefit here the main benefit
is that we were able to like actually
make changes to stuff um that was too
brittle to change before um and if if
anyone um would like to
come at me with like oh well you just
you didn't tdd hard enough on the rails
side um
i don't know what to tell you
that wasn't the problem
um
okay
um top three costs uh these are somewhat
similar somewhat different from elm um
so again fewer off the shelf sas
integrations um we did have to write our
own uh new relic integration for like
some server-side monitoring um for
haskell um
uh this is different from elm so the
learning curve for haskell is definitely
you know i mean you could argue that
it's like the number one cost to the
business um which is that i mean it's
just
elm is very easy to learn haskell is
very hard to learn um that's been my
experience uh we have in the past
multiple times um hired like fresh boot
camp grads like they've never had a
programming job before they pick up elm
in their first week um we have not since
we adopted haskell we have not been
hiring out of boot camps um but if we
had uh that's the conversation we would
have it's like okay how how were we
gonna have them learn haskell and
honestly probably what we would do the
strategy we would most likely do is um
have them learn elm first and just only
give them front-end projects when
they're starting out and then after
they've been using elm for a couple of
months then
incrementally move to haskell because
honestly i think if you're like one
person we hired actually never done
javascript either um she'd only done
python she went to a python bootcamp and
in her first week she actually thought
having never used ruby or elm um this is
before we done haskell uh she actually
commented i was like hey you know you're
more interested in learning more like
doing more elm projects or more ruby
projects she said i'm interested in
doing more elm projects because it feels
easier like elm for her was like easier
to learn than ruby which is an
object-oriented language like python
dynamically typed and elm felt easier
largely because the compiler is helpful
i think um
haskell again just it's just not the
case so um uh i think we would probably
just
try some strategy where people learn how
to learn elm first and then transition
to haskell um
but the number one cost um is honestly
just not unique to haskell at all it's
just transitioning away from the status
quo um we have a ton of legacy rails
code and uh you know like i said a lot
of it's like
pretty brutal to change unfortunately we
have a ton of tests but uh it's not
enough and so um this is not specific to
haskell because if we were moving to
elixir we would have the same number one
cost here uh which is you know
transitioning away from the uh
the status quo
i don't know what um to what extent that
would would have been true if we had
like a bigger react code base when we
were transitioning to elm but my sense
is that it's actually i think easier to
incrementally adopt things on the front
end than on the back end especially if
you have a a monolith like like we did
with rails because that's kind of what
rails encourages the majestic model if
they call it um
if we'd had like micro services maybe
this would be easier um probably it
would be easier but um micro services
have their own whole set of downsides so
i don't want to pretend like that's a
free lunch either um
but yeah i mean uh it definitely uh is
is like you know the main the main issue
that we have you know faced in
transition to haskell is just like how
do we do this incrementally it's just
harder to do in our experience than it
was on the front end with hell
okay um we have had some other like more
recent experiments uh nyx is one that's
been very successful we use nyx for like
all of our development dependencies we
use nixos for our ci runners um may end
up using it for our production servers
even potentially um
kubernetes also has gone well i know
there's like a big meme of like oh you
don't need kubernetes i don't want to
tell you we needed kubernetes
uh we we had a lot of very specific pain
points and we looked at what was out
there and it was either kubernetes or
like hashicorp nomad or something like
that but um as it happened we had
somebody who had kubernetes
experience so we ended up going with
that but like
we tried the route of like you know
yagni you're not getting gonna need it
and we found that no we actually didn't
need it um post graphite we tried out
but ultimately was not a successful
experiment but fortunately we did it on
in a pretty small controlled way as as
we do and we're able to sort of uh back
it out
okay
so to sum up um back in 2013 you know
very small company
no money no revenue uh no functional
programming um uh and then you know
basically uh between then and now like
uh we introduced react react grew uh
from react we transitioned to elm elm
grew sort of took over our front end and
then haskell and nyx came out of that um
uh we did you know controlled
experiments one after another the latest
of which has been haskell there will
certainly be others after that um and
this is our formula find a low risk
project that's a good fit get it all the
way into production expand it
credentially or if it doesn't work out
then back out
and essentially that's how we got from
2013 to where we are today you know five
employees to going to be over 100 by the
end of the year 60k lines of code to 1.2
million thousands of users to millions
of users
no revenue to actually literally turning
a profit
and uh we did it thanks to uh uh
functional programming
so that's how we got to millions of
users in purely functional code thanks
very much